[Music]
yo
yo yo hello
[Music]
bro i uh so [ __ ] tired
i don't know what's wrong with me i'm
like air i need air
how you guys doing
nice stream yesterday uh it was huge
huge win
uh we're gonna play game
i wanted to test this game out
just give me a minute and i'll set it up
it's called before your eyes
and it's supposed to use your webcam as
far as i understand unless i got the
wrong game
let me double check use this webcam
that's crazy
and i'm not sure how to set that up let
me see here
you guys can probably not see anything
can you you can
let's stretch that
boom
okay
[Music]
almost there
um
[Music]
okay how does this work how do i set up
my webcam with it that's the real
question new game
shouldn't it ask me to set it up first
there we go so i can't i can use this
one
hey i'm using my
uh phone as a webcam and it's sitting
like
next to me but there's my real cat this
is
yeah you get the gist uh with the camera
enabled
okay will track me
i consent to tracking if you do not have
a camera
no i have a camera are you wearing
glasses no
make sure evenly late
i is as good as it's gonna get
the circle below should fill in whenever
you blink
whoa how does he know
that's sick okay it seems to rework
what now
calibrate i don't think i need to look
at this screen and blink a few times
[Music]
yeah if the game stops detecting blinks
press spacebar to recalibrate
this is weird here we go
let me know if the audio is good volume
higher or lower
this game about blinking see every time
you blink
the game will notice see how this works
try blinking on on the white symbol
[Music]
it already doesn't work oh okay i move
there we go okay
[Music]
that's cool when you see a metronome and
blink
oh you'll jump forward keep blinking
oh this is freaky
i walk by blinking
i do it subconsciously obviously so i
don't think about it and then oh [ __ ]
i don't want to blink
i asked you for your name but sadly you
got no mouth to speak with
i only got my eyes hands to shake with
nose to look down with so
we're gonna have to find another way see
what you'll find is i'm actually a
master at not blinking your body
your body's still inside of you if that
makes
any sense sure so if you understand
what i'm saying um blink
over my hand here all right ready for it
you remember blinking oh look at that
you're a blinking genius
[Laughter]
game quiet all right let me turn that
see all them poor souls down there
lost in the waves i didn't choose any of
them
i chose you oh i'm special thank you i i
just
sometimes get a sort of a a hunch
or what's a better word epiphany
an inch inkling now you see that tower
out there
not yet oh whoa
that's where i'm taking you to see the
gatekeeper
to be judged i'm gonna present your case
tell her the whole story of your entire
life from prow
to stern now if she's impressed i'll get
paid the big coin
and you get yourself a spot in her
magnificent city
i'm in if she ain't well
i eat seagull for dinner again
[Laughter]
we don't have to worry about that
because i am the best orator you'll find
on these sickly waters
class a storyteller believe me
shut up you had your chances
it wasn't my fault you were no good
layabouts
i'm getting all my blinking out now you
know clock watchers
i got some roots is that it lexicon
[Music]
bro you got to work on your calves bro
so sure maybe i'm not the most verbose
storyteller out there
but i know how to spin a yarn if i'm
given
something to work with and that's where
you come in
your life you're going to show it to me
i want to see exactly what made you so
absolutely
great so just
think back okay very beginning
uh-huh no problem first thing that you
can remember
my first memory i'll send you there
pooping in a shower understand
no matter how much you like it you're
not going to be able to stay
all right every time you blink you're
going to jump
forward in time second that's cool
could be five years five years just how
this thing works
damn okay interesting i mean
i hope he's ready for this now the next
time that you blink
i'm gonna send you back don't be afraid
and don't try to fight it i am kind of
fighting it not gonna lie the thing to
remember about
blinking is well it's only a matter of
time
[ __ ] he's right i can
did i blank just try to enjoy it this
time all right
the thing is i wear contact lenses so i
can hold them up i can hold my blanks
longer
[Music]
look at that sun beautiful
i love the style of this it's been a
long beautiful day ahead of us
mm-hmm
why are you smiling like that i don't
know because the game was funny
oh i didn't mean to blink all night
i just did it intuitively
don't blink all right no more blinking
is that a stone with it all right
it's pretty
let's go get you some seashells what do
you say
sure
you see that big spiky plant over there
uh
[Music]
we'll have to keep our eyes on now
okay i'll be back mister ago god damn it
they really slipped away didn't it they
had the beach oh well
the best
no i keep blinking go ahead kid
[Music]
look at that there's your little hand
one year old we have to make him do this
i did not blink
you saw that should we recalibrate
make sure you're emailing lit uh-huh
i should move this a little bit is it
this way or this way it's this one oh
how do i should be like this why am i
why is it like not centered on me even
if i move it that makes no sense
it's not barely
okay
okay
okay great
oh you want to play along with mommy
don't you yes
see i didn't blink there i swear i
didn't maybe i'm blinking and i don't
even know
sounds good honey i'm sending it to my
mentor next week
it has to be perfect well sounds
pretty perfect to me yeah what do you
like about it
i also like the person playing it
[Music]
i'll just keep my eyes a bit wider open
look at his little face
what do you think he's thinking about
i don't know probably solving the
problems of the universe
are they talking about a baby yeah oh
these cars
they were the [ __ ] no it's not
derivative
at least i didn't think it was i'm
learning math
do you think you could tell science and
geometry what i just told you
right beautiful now that's sorry
i guess i just put a lot of expectation
on this call
what am i blinking i'm not even playing
thank you for considering my piece john
it really means a lot
well it's not it's not as good as mine
but
you know you try let's show our little
mess of color
[Music]
whoa hey we do not throw things in this
house
if you're mad that you aren't good
enough yet you'll just have to keep
working at it
sorry mom you know one day you'll be
able to paint exactly what you have in
your head
you'll be damn it
scrapbook
[Music]
baby grand piano gimme that
fan baithold see
that used to be my piano
my dad gave it to me he loved music
oh sweet fled his home country just to
have a chance to pursue it
god he made me practice so much
i hated it at first
man's got a pipe i want a pipe
[Music]
high school choir first unitarian
gray
i think he hoped to make it further than
conducting the high school choir
never said anything though he is what
you might call
the strong silent type i can't
blink can you believe i grew up in the
snow
and i came all the way out here to the
beach
i don't even know how i got here you're
dead
damn it oh i got an achievement eyes of
steel are you ready to see something
really special i just don't want him to
get attached
oh my god are we getting our sven
oh my god is it a sven
what's the cutest thing i've ever seen
oh what's wrong with that
we can't keep him can we i mean i'm
pretty much definitely allergic i'm not
blinking
no it's my uh as a demon
but while he's here i say we call him
ernie
ernie damn it
ernie
oh now play the c major chord i taught
you
yep
[Music]
there it is there you go doesn't that
make you feel happy
like you just want to jump up and down
now what about c
minor you remember how to play that one
of course very good
just one note different that one sounds
sad doesn't it
a little melancholic i would say mom
what a difference one little change can
make on how a person feels
[Music]
what do you think arnie sort of like me
and your little friend on your piano
there
[Music]
i want to enjoy this music and moment
with ernie
a little longer damn it
[Music]
she was in grad school studying
composition
i never met anyone like her i just
prayed to god i could somehow keep up
think she liked that i was a professor
gave me a certain
gravitas in her eyes you know
which i very quickly lost
[Music]
going through the memory book she
dragged me to so many places
it's wonderful oh
where would you want to go if you could
only go to one
[Music]
is that santorini i'll go there
well just remember to put on sunscreen
true
and i gave you some unfortunate
oh yeah let's hope they balance each
other out
[Music]
it automatically moves on if you don't
blink
which is probably a safe safe thing i
just noticed it there
i thought for
yeah the music looks great everything's
great i like it
we're growing up or year do you think
we're in now
we're in it for the big piano
[Music]
wait is that oh it plays so well
how did you figure out how to play that
richard
are you hearing this what
he's playing my piece oh i'm a guy i
figured it out by ear
i mean i was a gifted kid but he's
brilliant
we need to get him into serious piano
lessons
sure but you know anyone who might be a
good teacher for him
what i mean in the city sure not out
here i don't
i mean i know someone who might be up to
the tab
richard no one in this town knows
anything maybe
no damn it i actually blinked
[Music]
ernie
oh god i have my interview in five
minutes and i completely forgot to feed
him
i don't have to blink when these are oh
what can we do with ernie
you can scribble now that's a painting
picasso
abstract for a moment
excuse me of course sir it's all
organized into folders
sitting ready on my kitchen table i get
it literally be on your desk when you
get in life passes by you with a blank i
get it
between now and tomorrow morning you
want to enjoy the moment
[Music]
with ernie over here the game is giving
me
[Music]
i'm blinking my phone fell
there we go when's he coming
i'm flying him out in february remember
you know i think he was pretty surprised
that i could actually afford to do that
hey why not oh we're getting better now
yo mom's spaghetti yeah
[Music]
please let the cat know
it's time to use the litter box though
baby steps
he's got one eye no
this is called a metronome i don't like
it it's very frustrating so far
the metronome that is i want you to
start using it before grandpa comes to
visit
okay got all my blings out you know my
father once told me
when i was about your age the only way
to fight against time
is to create a work of genius which
might live on after you're gone
so i asked him what about your children
yeah thinking i might be a work of
genius just as i was
he said yes i suppose
if you made a work of genius i could
live on through that as well
no such luck for me
i haven't seen him in over 10 years can
you believe that
sounds like a very harsh father with
skewed ideas of life
i blinked
[Music]
what is that phone call is that a bad
phone call i feel like it's a bad one
i ain't blinking can't make me
i got eyes of steel baby
[Music]
golden eyes i think i have to blink
all right
has passed piano pieces for children
clavier stick
i want to play i don't want to blink
damn it
there you go buddy okay now keep a firm
grip on it
just like that we're taking a photo of
ernie
[Music]
sorry buddy turn around l
so we can photograph you i get to
no way oh i'm just
really behind right now why don't you
take photos in the backyard
it may not be interesting at first but
if you keep going back out there every
day
you'll be surprised by how much it
changes okay good advice
i'm blinking consciously in one two
three
[Music]
i love the music
no don't say that
what did you just say no i i said i'm
really worried
here can i get a kitty how dare you make
a joke out of ernie's disappearing
i know sweetie it cuts
thank god i heard he's safe it
disappears for weeks and then comes back
with a huge belly
but ernie's a boy and you're sure about
that
how do they not figure that out by now
and that was based off
[Music]
if it's further away or something then
it's one or the other
and what was ernie's
[Music]
i'm still
we keep it even though i hate cats and
now it just happens to pop out
five more well he should have neutered
it
[Music]
he keeps coloring the grass blue the
ocean
yes
[Music]
i meant book oh yeah
[Music]
okay i'm blinking i'm just trying to
look around you know
see what's happening
[Music]
it's getting spooky again
i assume uh her dad passed away that's
what the call was about
what is that creepy sound that cannot be
ernie or nia
i'm blinking
i know it seems impossible that you
could ever play something so complex
i can do it but just take it
one day at a time trust me
[Music]
that this song everyone gets taught
first
is that what it was called and that was
beethoven
spooky
it's not even that hard bro come on the
quiz said find the zero
and he just drew an arrow pointing to it
what's wrong with that i mean everything
is wrong with that
i want to see my answers
wow
[Music]
how do you get that
[Music]
uh-huh benjamin
that's our name
[Music]
everything changes so fast you don't
play with it anymore we're getting rid
of it
no not baba the bear
can he stay congratulations
for so many ah dang it
i covered my face
[Music]
we got neighbors moving in ooh potential
uh
neighbor love interest
gotta make a good first impression here
[Music]
to be fair hey you yeah
you come over here
okay yes mr camera boy i'm talking to
you
sure
this is our first interaction with the
other sex
why are you always out here taking
photos so i'm a creep
you know if you really want to take a
photo of something cool
you should take a photo of this
wow that is very cool
oh it's time why did they do this my
i play guitar right and my parents are
all whenever family is over it's like
felix
is going to play the guitar now and he's
like why did you put why
wow l he's unbelievable my god i didn't
realize our head of accounting was
raising a musical
prodigy i don't even have to look my
eyes are closed
no the class is world history
my name is mr isaac the class will be
broken up into you
hey i wrote you something
okay what do we got
uh dear weird neighbor kid thanks
we are in the same class what a
coincidence please please keep in mind
that while we're at school
we don't know each other do not talk to
me ever
assass not doodle on the sidelines not
stare off into space
all right let's take some notes okay
let's see here
done okay
now i will go on to the next slide
chloe tell me what did the quote say
um oh you need my help now huh you
were taking notes weren't you clown
so those who do not remember damn it
i tried to convince your father not to
buy you that thing
suspect he bought it for himself what a
poppy
the little guy cone master looks amazing
oh i want the job of whoever gets paid
to think of that crap
oh they made fun the developers made fun
of themselves that's great
i've definitely seen you next door
oh sure we sit together in history class
i don't know what i do without old benny
that's me thank you for playing his game
with him
your dad just thanked me for hanging out
with you
very interesting detail okay shut up
shut up
i really want this one are we playing
pokemon
[Music]
damn good call
[Music]
oh yeah i remember always drawing
it's called a magnet all the characters
from video games i drew a pretty sick
yoshi i'm not gonna lie
i'm the neighbor's kid damn it
it's about an hour away in a town called
burton i know the change can be scary
we're moving to a music school go in and
meet the dean i spoke with
you know life can take you to some
incredible places
if you're really really good at
something
or you can just be a youtuber honestly
you have to be good at anything
blinking consciously so what do you
think benjamin
you think you could excel in that sort
of an environment
yeah this seems like a great place i
love it
sorry he gets very shy oh
not to worry oh my god she's as gifted
as you say he is
shyness is no problem why don't you two
come back
closer to the end of the year for an
audition
we'll get a few pieces that you can have
him start learning
i'm eager to hear what your son is
capable of
blinking oh no i understand you were a
musician yourself
where did you study yeah mom
berkeley but i was in the composition
department
i didn't blink the game blinked
all right let's read bach as you can see
there are some very fast runs in there
and a lot of stuff i've not taught you
properly yet so no pressure
i just want you to try and we can see if
you start enjoying it
being shy is a superpower just like to
see you
really rise to the occasion just this
once
i wish i had the option of going to a
school like that when i was your age
i wouldn't be working this boring job or
living in this boring town i'll tell you
that
crumble what was that was that the piece
there's choices in the game with you
these days i barely know whose kid
you're supposed to be
no i will not throw it at my mom
face until addition all right well time
to practice
don't answer that ben but it could be my
neighbor kid
after you practice
it's really hard to play this i mean
like
doing the blinking and all that oh my
god
is she really calling you again what is
she obsessed with
you got a problem with that mom hi
chloe what's that what are you doing i
explicitly asked you not to pick up the
phone
who you remember is the goddess of truth
and justice
would weigh the deceased soul against
the feather
determining whether it was worthy of
entering into her land
of the dead and what if they are deemed
unworthy
well you can see that ugly fur ball
under the scale
that is alma met and she's got
and yes that's a she the head of a
crocodile
fur of a lion see
i get to decide the conversation
look at it oh she slid me enough she is
ready to devour
any of tonight after my dad goes to
sleep i'm going to sneak out my house
and go to sleep on the beach
if you want to get invited draw me a
picture why is it blurry
so i am not quite sure of mr isaac
feeling constipated
oh he's gonna see the note
done what's so funny
okay i'll call you when i'm leaving my
house you better
pick up my call dude oh
okay slightly worried about having him
change schools
just because he's starting to make
friends yeah i'm pretty sure the only
reason she keeps coming here is to play
that
game you bought for him okay
benny has a chance here a real chance to
be really good at something
parents projecting their ideas onto a
child
[Music]
no i suppose you're right oh richard
please
like that
some interesting themes i like it
i don't think it's a bad mom necessarily
cozy room out you need to be rested for
tomorrow
memory consolidates when you're asleep
so if you go to sleep now
you will awaken a master trust me
mom what is consolidate me
mom close the door close the door
you forgot to close the door now i got
to go up
so cozy
benny damn it benny turn those lights
off did anybody your mom want the light
benny we went fine i'm going to beach
anyway
stupid oh there it is
we're sneaking out with chloe i mean
come on
i'm a sticky for a baby i apologize
okay so meet me out in the alley in t
minus now okay uh-huh
oh wow this is creepy she said you know
mommy
i'm really glad you're here
there's something i've been meaning to
talk to you about
or to get off my chest
okay i don't
think concerts is actually a really good
game
as in yoon he was in town this weekend
and he was explaining how it's actually
you know
really good japanese i wonder which one
he calls it
so i'm sorry that i made you like it
because it's
actually a terrible
[Laughter]
but i also think that if it was a really
good game
maybe we wouldn't have enjoyed playing
it as much
we would have been so focused on how
good it was
and not the feelings we had while we
were playing it
good point my favorite vegetable is the
tomato
thinks that they're the grossest ever
they are the grossest ever he's right
or she i don't know he's a popular boy
in the school uh-huh thank you
i also like hanging out with you the
most
which was also something i wanted to
talk to you about
damn it i blinked probably didn't sleep
at all
out in the cold all night oh she's mad
i'm sick aren't you
it's okay you still got this i mean all
the practice had to count for something
maybe just try and close your eyes now
and get a little sleep on the way over
i'm going to play the recording so the
sound of mastery can seep into your
subconscious a little okay
close your eyes ben i'm going to be
there soon
[Music]
this is weird are you guys closing your
[Music]
eyes
it's pretty
must play well
i know this i got this
in your own time benjamin we are very
excited to hear
well this is fun
sounds terrible i'm totally rooney
oh okay okay i think that's enough
ah
you don't like it so benjamin
uh why don't we plan on having you
come back next year again once you've
had a bit more time to
practice yes as you know
burton isn't the right fit for him
oh no what if i don't get into burton
wherever it may take you okay
all right [ __ ] you i i really want to
thank you
and your mother for coming all the way
out here i know it was
quite the drive oh mom is going to be
pissed dude maybe i pushed you too hard
yes you did
maybe i turned into my own father it
seems like it i don't know
yeah time to question yourself something
to focus on
the world isn't very kind to people who
aren't really good at
something no that it's basically
everyone so i wouldn't worry about him
on
we want him home from school for a while
just until this nasty thing clears
hey l would you mind taking a quick walk
with me down to my office
there's a small clerical thing i need
you to look at before i can let you two
go
oh yes of course what happened i'll be
right back benny okay
just maybe five minutes kiddo okay
whoa
i can i cannot blink in five minutes
that's fine
no problem
this is fine we'll just wait
damn it it's a crucial time in his
development
he shouldn't be confined to his room
having him home for long
damn it
we're at the beach again is that
no it was over here
or was it am i 11 now
i'm right at the beach again
blinking consciousness video game time i
want you to figure out something
actually productive to do while you're
home from school
wow mom you're so much fun
you're too much fun honestly i can't
keep up with you
i know parents mean well obviously
my god they can be suffocating huh
blinking consciously
[Music]
hey
it's about from the beginning
another music
blinking consciously let's try it
we like to draw mom
you just never notice
[Music]
blinking consciously
[Music]
i need to learn how to center him but
you know it might be a
artistic choice now that's a boat
[Music]
and mr benjamin brynn has been awarded
first place
in two paragraphs describe what makes
you want to pursue a career in the arts
that's brilliant
[Music]
we're getting in for sure you are not
here to learn to be
free you are here to learn
which is ironic isn't it
love it i love it you ponies
never heard that insult before
hey how's ernie doing can we excuse me
what is happening here
how old am i i don't know if i want to
try that
[Music]
oh yes that's more like it how very
wacky
and fun these are
[Music]
oh yeah very zany very cute
lovely the world is always in
wait what happened oh it's another
drawing
how are we getting that minimalistic
style
there you go mr brain
thank you
[Music]
feel each shape
i do
oh honestly it's terrible
i want you all to take a long look at
what mr brynn has done here
yeah please go ahead
you fools he has reached down
deep within himself and created a
masterpiece i just squiggled away
honestly
alfred heart expo chronic sincerity of
this piece is so
sincerely ironic it is indeed the
discourse
so thoroughly i'm actually dizzy
[Music]
thank you
wash and fall
and it all probably feels weird and
alienating and
the opposite of what being a starving
artist is supposed to feel like
but if i can teach you one thing it's
that if
opportunity knocks you open the door
okay making a living isn't selling out i
wish i had thought of it that way
i got the wrong one
[Music]
he loves it he loves my art you're not
selling your
we took a job at a firm
i don't believe it
i mean it would make our mom happy it
doesn't hurt doesn't it
you've crumpled my contract
i actually didn't mean to do that
whatever you want kid
sure you got talent but what's talent
[Music]
listen i wish you the best of luck okay
okay we're done
[Music]
remember sign a contract early learn it
from me
[Music]
ah this is divine so
now that you've grown bro do you ever
wear a clean shirt
where will you fly to the stars
just somewhere abroad this american air
can be stifling
we're moving fast now
[Music]
where are we now whoa i like that
where is santorini
we're mixing styles i like it
[Laughter]
in your entire career collectors
curators how we all love a rising star
and how bored we become once it's
settled
keep rising benjamin right
i think it was that good but okay hey
ben
don't even pick up this call okay i mean
it
i'm just calling to inform you that i
went to the doctor today
and well i'm i'm gonna be a little sick
for a while
but really i i don't want you worrying
about it at all
you're such an important moment in your
career and
i'm just so proud of you but i answered
but
that's enough for me now
you'll hear from me no i believe is the
single thing in the world
my wife was most proud of her
magnum opus so to speak
huh i think you all know who i'm talking
about
benny ready to come up here
[Music]
go on b say something
what's wrong why aren't you talking
[Music]
hey you as you know i talk to big
very important people every day and
there's one thing that everybody is
asking me
[Music]
you are a snake you're a fraud
but worst of all benjamin you're a
little tease
i have told the world that benjamin
brain
is a genius i have told the world that
benjamin brain
is silent because benjamin brain is
hard at work creating his greatest work
yet
but you are doing nothing
hey b just calling to tell you
i think i'm selling the house
she's everywhere your son i can't
move without bumping into her
and i just find myself breaking down
again
i hope you understand
take whatever you want with your mother
gone i'm hoping to finally live without
all the clutter
well we're definitely keeping mr boat by
the way
she didn't want you to see her like that
she just wanted you to focus on your
work
that is the only thing that matters oh
that is a tough one
it's getting stressful okay
[Music]
oh oh that's what it
[Music]
became
out okay
[Music]
look it's unbelievable benny
oh so she's standing in the room with us
[Music]
made it pretty her in the paint
i can feel her
[Music]
oh well
[Music]
inspired by the musical composition of
his late mother the composer l stevens
relatively unknown in her life
prince lifted his mother work out
obscurity with the creation of this
piece oh wow
oh my god i can't believe it oh it's
neighbor kid
i just walked through the entire show
it's unbelievable oh okay
i'd love to walk through it again with
you i mean if you were down
for that yes yes yes yes
i just can't believe that my entire
childhood
i was living next to a bona fide genius
and your mom i always heard her playing
piano from next door
but i didn't know she wrote the actual
music
oh hey so
not to be forward but so she became what
her dad wanted her to be
maybe we could get a drink or something
i'd really love to catch up i can't
believe everything that's happened to
you
what's going on
you finally hit the jackpot flapjack all
the
nobody nothing's dying every day you
finally sink your hook into
whoa well there you are
well hello sir
if i realized i would have cleaned up
i'm just used to fishing up a different
class of soul
i mean close scientists a couple college
athletes here or there
but an
internationally renowned painter
the gatekeeper's gonna eat you up okay
speaking of that why don't we give your
story a test run
maybe you help me out the word choice
since you know i'm still working on that
fair
see if i'm getting all the strokes right
the proper
composition if you catch my drift
forget about it all right here we go
gatekeeper before you stands the soul of
a
great man thank you now
would you describe yourself as a happy
kid
or a lonely one well you can be both
i'll be happy his childhood was a happy
one
growing up in a loving home raised by
loving parents
in a quaint village by the sea
and uh what'd you say your mom was a
composer
or an accountant his mother was a
composer
who with the need to support her family
took a job as an accountant
how would you describe her as a teacher
more
encouraging or demanding
oh kind of like your champion
or or more like a task master
she was both i guess
can i blink here
i guess demanding that's the truth
therefore
as his piano teacher she was over
demanding
forcing him to practice day in and day
out
hoping that he might one day achieve
that greatness that she never
could
how about that neighbor girl what was
she to you
was she your best friend
or your first love and be honest here
i don't know i really don't be bashful
man you can tell me i mean i wanted
romance to develop but i wouldn't say
i wouldn't say uh let's go with mom
but on the eve of his big audition he
completely dropped the ball staying up
all night with his
first love and blowing it the next day
[Music]
now from that moment forward his mother
gave up on him
she knew he didn't have what it took to
be a truly great musician
but little did she know she just picked
the wrong medium
that's right see
when he was 12 years old he got
sick and he had to stay inside for an
entire year
it was that long in that year he
rediscovered a talent
he'd forgotten painting
[Music]
color and shape were the first languages
he learned to speak
but for the first time he saw it in a
more serious life
he was accepted into an exclusive art
school
where he caught the eye of an esteemed
professor who
launched his work into the national
spotlight
but be quiet with expectations on his
career mounting
he stalled himself i'm really glad we
threw away the contract to be a blessing
for it wasn't until he returned home to
the house he grew up in
that he began working on what would
ultimately be considered his masterpiece
i said shut up
[Applause]
i like his vocabulary
all right i get it
i hear what you're saying
oh it's opening
it assumed as much anyway
i should probably tell you those things
they're not regular goals uh-huh they're
liar birds
oh oh they're what becomes of souls who
tried to lie
to the gate they try that
they're never allowed near her city
again
hey i don't even know if i want to go
there feeling bad for not defending them
right so
they just stay on with me living
reminders of my
oratory shortcomings
good thinking i'll be back to get you
once i'm done with this one
we haven't lied so far
this is awkward silence what's happening
thank you thank you just look at him and
shut up
is this an elevated oh wow
oh
now don't think that i haven't dealt
with people like you oh my god i'm
ashamed of something something so
terrible
you're trying to blink right past it
because if the gatekeeper knew she'd
have to dream up fresh new hells to
punish someone as worthless
oh it's reacting to my blank and i'm
sure you're right i'm sure you're the
rotten soul
that i ever fished out of that black
muck
and i should have thrown you back and
sanitized my paw as soon as i laid eyes
on you
but it's too late for that we're in this
together
and the gatekeeper she'll see right
through your fake lies as if they were
glass
bro chill i didn't lie i'm gonna ask you
again
to start from the did i did i lie and
this time
i want the truth no
all right i'm blinking
are we back at the beach
[Music]
what did i fail or
is this supposed to be part of the
i didn't lie here c major chord
[Music]
come on keep blinking i i i haven't
found you oh okay it's supposed to be
part of the game
you know my father once told me when i
was about your age
the only way to fight against time is to
create a work of
genius this
stupid oh what what did your mother hear
on that phone call
about her dad
[Music]
oh god i can't blink
am i doing this right
do i blink to go forward or
keep your eyes open i need
to see okay
oh my god it's so hard let's try this
again
okay i got this
i have some steel baby
i kind of blinked there didn't i
no thank god
i'm getting it
hello yes of course this is l
his daughter oh no
[Music]
oh
[Music]
she knew she hadn't yet lived up to her
father's expectations
and now she never could
let's keep going
[Music]
you really need to stay in time with the
metronome okay you were a prodigal
talent
i get it let's move one okay
what did you just say this isn't a trip
down memory lane
i need yes i understand
about the cat let's keep
[Music]
speed running
uh this is the other creepy memory
i don't know what happened here i don't
[ __ ]
it's really hard your eyes open okay
[Music]
not blinking
[Music]
easy
those cats must have taught you a
terrifying lesson
that simply being alive wasn't enough
so then you went to work to make
yourself sensational
[Music]
listen to him richard i'm enlisting him
in that competition
don't psychoanalyze me wolf not if you
[Music]
win
i know you want to stay here man but we
don't have the time
for me this year
[Music]
hey l would you mind taking a quick walk
with me down to my office
oh my god
[Music]
i need eye drops dude
my ac is on it's blowing in my eyes
i think on
okay i think i'm back sorry i paused the
game because it was lagging
i'll just wait for everyone to come back
once i
you're back get your blinking act
because we're continuing
here we go
[Music]
tell everyone to refresh if it doesn't
work
i need to hear what they're saying
really
try to recall it well i don't remember
because i never experienced it
am i supposed to close my eyes i mean
what's the point
what do you mean what
what happened
what's the point
[Music]
what does that mean
what's the point of any of it
that's right mom think like a true
nihilist
for yourself if he's never gonna get any
better from the societal
pressure okay let's not
say that okay
we know we don't mean it i know i don't
i know i mean
what if he heard one of us saying
something like that
i'd never forgive myself no i
it's okay he's asleep but
it's okay
damn i see
you got sick you howled at the moon
the top of your lungs
it's a tree the beech tree
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
give me back rna you were sick for a
long time
weren't you sicker than
healthy kids are supposed to get
well no matter how painful it gets i
need you
to remember we're
almost at the end of this i promise
all right we're back being sick then
this isn't video game time
i want you to figure out something
actually productive to do while you're
home from school
but i did wait what am i writing with it
this is another path we could have taken
well hello benny
it was your grandfather's but i used it
in college to write lyrics
exactly it was very artsy actually i was
just good at fooling your dad
made him think i was some kind of genius
why don't you write the story of your
life so far
and then what you're going to do once
you get better that's the story i want
to hear
story of who you're going to become okay
linking consciously the great life of
benjamin
brin
[Music]
his childhood was a happy one
growing up in a loving home
raised by loving parents
in a quaint
village by the sea
his mother was a composer
who with the need to support
her family took a job
as an accountant
blinking consciously
man this is wild
you really got into this didn't you
oh here i am but on the eve of his big
audition
he completely dropped the ball staying
up all night with his first love
and blowing it the next day first
love okay benny
and you know we really could have just
slept on the beach another night
but i'm also glad we didn't because well
another night wouldn't be the same night
if that makes sense
okay uh back to the story
he'd love finger painting as a child
color and shape were the first languages
he learned to speak
man you take your doodle seriously
i did not realize but i respect it
thank you i respect it
i do i said thanks
all right blinky i'm so confused where
is this going with the writing you were
going to be
in there for about 30 minutes they did
cut we did cut past these memories
really quickly so there was a big gap in
our memory then
was taken out
you're doing great buddy thank you
knock back you're gonna be so annoyed
with me
but i couldn't help but overhear chloe
reading loud from what i think was your
story the other night
i know i know i promised myself i
wouldn't eavesdrop but mom
i would really love to read it if you'd
let me what do you say
you know i'm such a big fan of anything
you do oh
i can't just go in there and tell him
you loved it
i'm sorry i just can't what
not right now okay don't worry just
go to bed i'll talk to you
hey b just want you to know that
mom loved your story she's just yeah i
think it was just very
emotional for her to read but i
thought it was great
i mean look at this his childhood was a
happy one
growing up in a loving home raised by
loving parents
in a quaint village by the sea
certainly glad you feel that way but
what i want to know is
where'd you learn to write so well well
this wolf guy
reads like dickens oh
benjamin brynn was a loser
he was the worst friend
to ever live
he didn't even try to
find the disease
inside him
he just laid down and died
[Music]
damn
penny then oh god can you hear me
richard
richard get out
i'm up what's going on i think he's
unconscious
call the paramedics now okay
okay i'm doing it
that's your moment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
try closing your eyes it might help you
remember so if he's ever in pain all he
needs to do is press that red button and
the drug will administer itself
thank you so much you know i know my
wife would normally want to
thank you herself no i understand it
hits mothers the hardest this sort of
thing
thank you for understanding it's been
it's been a rough one
[Music]
at least we're at home
hey eddie yeah hey man it's
richard listen i know l's been
missing in action but i just want you to
understand things have taken a
really bad turn here
yeah no that's not going to be possible
to be honest your whole tone is
pissing me off right now
yes i understand you have a business to
run
it's a very cliche thing to say to me
in a time like this
okay well
well then i guess all i can say is screw
you too
i said screw you too
yeah man that's all i got
damn all right
then this game all right close calling
hey this isn't funny you know what
you're too scared to talk to me
well just so you know i know you're
faking
because if you were really sick like
actually sick
you'd have told me already i happen
hey benny buddy did you just
yeah i throw stuff dad i remember when
you were just
four years old you got the mustang tough
time i mean
not as tough as now but yeah her music
had been rejected
and she's having trouble adjusting to
her quiet little life out here chloe can
[ __ ] out of here i feared that
yeah i was losing her
but then you played this on the piano
and just your little heads reaching
keys she just couldn't believe how
gifted you were
once she heard that well it was like you
brought her right back to me
oh so
i was wondering if maybe you could do
that trick again
try closing your eyes see if you can
remember
oh there we go i'm thinking
i'm memorizing can you guys see anything
[Music]
how did you figure out how to play that
oh
am i supposed to open oh here we go
oh it's pretty
he's playing b she's listening
[Music]
[Music]
to stay my dudes
what are you doing here you furball what
are you doing now
she's gonna make you sick
oh it's okay i'm just so happy she's
here
we've got to show this cat some real
love
she's been through more than we can even
imagine
[Music]
oh her poor fur richard we have to give
ernie a haircut okay
i don't get it is she okay what happened
what time are we in
[Applause]
[Music]
she hasn't been over like she didn't
even care to visit
no i mean i don't think he's told her
and you're just letting that be
i don't know her step you know how benny
is
she lost her mother a year ago you knew
that right
no what does that have to do with do we
have our dad's number
i don't know check the book okay i'm
calling now
honey
[Music]
oh my god you're an idiot
uh maybe like another 30 minutes
okay
you do realize this is really nothing
special to me
i've seen this all before i
um i was thinking about what you said in
the story the other
day and how i reacted to it
i feel kind of bad i shouldn't have done
that
but
hey what are you looking at
don't worry about it don't look up there
look at me
i'm talking to you
i want to give you something but i think
i don't want to be in the room when you
see what it is
so maybe if you close your eyes
i can give it to you and i'm going to
leave
close your eyes now oh okay
here we go
is it safe to open
dear weird neighbor kid
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i hate this part
[Music]
what is that it's something new i'm
working on so
you're writing again ah it's just a
melody that came to me
it feels good to play it
[Music]
it's sad yeah well that would make sense
but do you like it i mean yeah
i love everything you do what do you
like about it
oh not this old trap go on
i'm waiting well it made me
feel like like
like if the unspeakable darkness i'm
carrying can be so
well expressed maybe it's not so
unspeakable
nailed it didn't i yeah i mean that was
pretty good
it's wednesday my dudes
it's two's oh it's getting tougher
[Music]
we can't even close our eyes anymore
[Music]
come on blob get the [ __ ] out of here
i can't breathe i know i know
it's okay benny i understand there's no
need to show me
anymore no richard it's like i can't
breathe
like there's this clamp on my chest i
know
it's okay you can come back to me now
prepare me you have to do something
richard i can't breathe i feel like i
can't breathe
it's okay benny just close your eyes
no
fine
you know for a while now i've wondered
if i'm just
not a good enough storyteller if i just
don't have grand enough words
can't tell grand enough stories
but grand words and stories i think they
may be overrated
i know just what to tell her
watch for her now i've seen the
gatekeeper take
many forms depending on the soul i bring
her
but once you see her you'll know
believe me okay i should go get ready
beautiful don't worry we got this
i think
i was hoping we would grow old
but i guess we never did
i'm keeping my eyes on oh
no way
[Music]
he's got his third eye she of course
[Music]
gatekeeper before you sits the soul of a
child who died before he could grow old
that means she's ready to hear your
story
blinking you know i never told you how
much i loved your story
it's really so imaginative
and the person you wrote about is such
an
interesting and intense guy my only
issue was
well i didn't like him very much
so i wanted to read you something i
wrote for you
which is about the benny i've known for
11 years now
it's called the great life of benjamin
brynn
benjamin brynn was born into an ordinary
home
to an ordinary mother and father in a
small town by the sea
his mother was a composer or at least
that's what she dreamed she'd be
so when her own dreams didn't pan out
she began to dream
for him but then
when he was just 11 years old
he got sick and was forced to stay
inside for an entire year
no no i blanked he began to worry
that he had so he made up us
of the great life he thought he wanted
to live
which only made him forget the great
life he already had
how he had filled a new home with light
and joy and promise
how he met a girl his neighbor who felt
all alone in the world
and made her feel okay again and how
even when he was sick he still gave his
parents hope
how he reminded them exactly who they
were
after they had almost forgotten
so when he knew he was going to go he
was okay
because he'd already lived a great life
a full life
and he was everything he needed to be
just as he was
[Music]
close your eyes now and keep them closed
she's gonna let you in
go on you know what to do
[Music]
oh i have to look i'm just cutting on
this here mate why is he smiling like
that
he must be somewhere that he likes
[Music]
oh wow wow
[Music]
that was incredible
i
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
that was so nice that was beautiful i
love that
i had no idea what to expect
cool lifestyle great story
fun elements beautiful score
that was so cool i love that
[Music]
you'll remember why you came here
[Music]
there's a couple pictures
thanks for joining me on that guys hope
you enjoyed it as well
sorry about my unintentional blinking
but i
i think i did it too many times
was such a good game
it's really fun playing too i recommend
checking out yourself
[Music]
try it out with the blinking
[Music]
all right i actually have to go after
this
i need to help out a little bit
but that was cool
[Music]
makes sense to end it here anyway
that was a kickstarter project
[Music]
maya stop working
all right we don't need to see all the
kickstarters no offense
hey
what up all right guys thanks for
joining this stream this might like to
subscribe
see you next time bye bye brofist
double bro fast